I woke up in London at 7:00
brush my teeth took a xiaolin walked
down to this famous shopping street on
my way to the - which had this
department store that ordered me to lust
for this red purse it used to be it was
enough just to want to have a handbag
but now we're so demented with the mania
of owning things that you have to feel
sexually attracted to your handbags
immediately thereafter I got Starbucks
and felt the waves of hypocrisy wash
over me I hate myself then I was on an
amazingly fast escalator and then an
amazingly fast train and there's Alex de
perak and there's Charlie so cool like
who was watching wheezy waiter on
YouTube when we arrived at their flat hi
I'm charlie then Charlie made me some of
his famous tea which tastes like a
triple rainbow and then Alex wrote a
quiz to me from his favorite Woman's
Weekly magazine which is called pick me
up - which he has a two year
subscription then we did what YouTube
nerds do when they meet in real life we
watched YouTube got on the train again
then I went to Piccadilly Circus to meet
up with ink master Tom lead of I and
nerdfighter Toby Oz - who my half of the
world Grayson Will Grayson is dedicated
where'd we go Tom
Funland consisted mostly of committing
simulated murder Tobias played a game
and I am NOT making this up called
elevator action death parade then we
sell Leicester Square and Big Ben and
this guy's head and a place where Sir
Isaac Newton had lived and a huge line
that someone had widely covered in metal
to keep him from attacking and this
busted bust of the affer mentioned Isaac
Newton which reminded me of the last
words of an American general how do I
look in the face then I got to hang out
with lots of nerdfighters at a bookstore
they wanted to say good morning yeah so
one of them had a ukulele version of
your guitar and a lot of them were in
the pen15 Club but then my secret sister
Rosie and I headed to the east edge of
this basement club called ice father
nation where I was scheduled to read
while Edie Plante Tom Milsom and Alex
Day were scheduled to play music as
father nation isn't the sort of place
that hosts a lot of book signings and at
first I was really nervous that no one
was going to show up but then I went
upstairs and the line was like this and
I got worried that too many people had
shown up which was in fact the case so
we ended up having to have two seperate
shows one enus father nation
[Applause]
and one in the waiting room upstairs it
was a totally magical night at least for
me at one point the club's owner came up
to me and said this is the most people
we've had since Mick Jagger's son played
here that mitad Lee I didn't know Mick
Jagger had a son but still anyway
everybody wanted to say hello to you of
course then I stayed up almost all night
and got on a train to Edinburgh when one
is travelling there's quite a lot of
travelling involved cows then I was in
Edinburgh with lots of made of awesome
nerdfighters at the top of this
beautiful hill which I described with my
trademark eloquence it's all skal indeed
they wanted to say good morning Hank
sometimes I feel like my job is to go
around the world and make sure that
every single person who wants to say
good morning to you has the opportunity
to do so
[Applause]
[Music]
it was just impossibly beautiful up
there looking over the city and songs
from Paul was singing songs from Paul
and everything was so utterly Hogwarts
Ian oh and there was this thing in
Edinburgh this thing is called the folly
because they were trying to build a
replica of the Parthenon but then they
ran out of money so they only got this
for some reason looking at the folly
made me think about fun land and that
person Newton's bust Hank I know it
doesn't feel this way all the time but
we get to choose what we care about and
what we spend our resources on we choose
one or ideally whom to lust after we
choose what to watch what - like what to
build how to spend the breaths that
we've been allotted and the fact that
many of our choices are unconscious get
that handbag get that Starbucks look at
that Snooki does not in any way make us
less responsible for those choices I'm
happiest when I feel like I'm part of
the community that helps me choose more
intelligently and with greater empathy
and I for one like the choices we made
this weekend so thanks to nerdfighteria
and thanks to you Hank I'll see you on
Wednesday
[Applause]